our unemployment benefits to new welfare
short-term resistance uh becoming
long-term trap report warrants
expanded federal unemployment benefits
put in place as emergency measuring
during the kobe 19 pandemic are on
course to become another long-term
welfare trap
a government fiscal watchdog group warns
in a new report
it has started to look more like welfare
and
it has started to look more like welfare
and more like another piece of the
welfare package it's starting to look
like
a long-term benefits program rather than
a short-term temporary supplement it was
supposed to be
alific a senior research fellow with the
foundation for government accountability
said
unemployment insurance programs should
promote work and reject government
dependency
for example an individual can receive
three thousand seven hundred dollars a
month or more than forty four thousand
dollars by staying home
the report continues on top of tax
credits food stamps and state
unemployment benefits an individual can
receive
an additional thirteen hundred dollars a
month with the three hundred dollars
weekly unemployment bonuses are you
kidding me that's 60k
a year to stay home and not do anything
yeah yeah it's it's um
you want to be humanitarian you want to
be sensitive and there are people that
want to go back to work but they have
child care issues and there's still some
covet issues out there
but there's a lot of people to come back
to work if you stop the you know a lot
of people want to stay home
because listen let's face it if you're
getting paid to stay home a lot of
people are going to do that
if you're one of those people out there
doing this okay i totally get it
the government is taking all of our
money and putting in their pockets get
yours i get it
but be careful don't stay out too long
man
if you stay out too long and you lose
your edge the the the marketplace is
going to pass you by
well there's a few things that are going
on already to your point you know
amazon's already coming up with robotics
and artificial intelligence because
they're not waiting for people to come
back in addition to that you've got a
lot of individuals that
if you've ever watched somebody that
stayed out and then come back in it's
tough to catch up because technology
changes and evolves so quickly so to
your point about losing your edge
the edge that even if you have an edge
individually you've got
a lot of catch-up work to do because
technology is constantly changing so
even six months is a long time to stay
out all three of you hire and i don't
when you look at somebody they've been
out for a year and a half do you do you
say
no do you say this is what what's the
reason why this is not the person for us
what do you see when there's uh uh an 18
month lapse in in a resume
so so there's four there's four
qualities i look for when i hire people
it seems to work it's attitude aptitude
initiative and a sense of urgency so if
you have all four of those i could teach
you the rest but um
attitude is really really important
initiative so somebody's
you know staying home that definitely
doesn't count in the initiative a sense
of urgency you know
that's that's another one that doesn't
doesn't really help uh so i think if you
have those four qualities
then you'd probably be a really good
hire does that sense of urgency ring a
bell oh my gosh john carter eight uh
keys to leading change absolutely that's
number one that's number one absolutely
sense of urgency is very hard to win
that's some questions about the topic
well just to follow up
okay just just real quick so if somebody
was out they took the full 18 months
they took the full two years yeah
is that a red flag for you on the resume
like straight up is it absolutely yes
it is absolutely yeah by the way you
know a lot of people will say things
like this listen
um i'll give you an example
uh we we have situ i run a company with
a lot of different agents nationwide and
you know you'll have a lot of people
that will use
excuses and listen all of us may use
excuses at certain times of our lives
but some more than others there isn't
anybody that's 100 percent hey
i never made an excuse about anything
people sometimes have a tendency to take
an easy way out some of the guys that we
follow and our leaders are people that
typically make the least excuses and you
admire them you see this guy is freaking
going places i just want to be able to
work with this guy
if you buy into the vision when we do
interviews and somebody says
um you know those two years of my resume
that you don't see anything
i took those two years off to take care
of a friend of mine or an aging parent
or this
so you sit there and you you what you
have to do in that moment you have to
say what
either they're telling the truth or
they're not telling the truth
right now in your mind there could be an
odds thing you could say
80 probably this is bs i don't buy it
80 is you work for a company for two
years they fired it was so bad you don't
want to put the boss's name on there
because you don't want us to make a
reference call
and if we make the reference call
they're going to say i'd never hire this
person
you don't want to hire this person so
that happens because sometimes
we'll go online and we're still able to
find where they work and we'll make the
reference call and by calling somebody
who is their former employer and will
ask do you know what job they went to
next sometimes they'll say
yeah you know he went and left us to go
work with xyz company because they gave
him a bigger raise
oh okay great then you call that off
which office was that xyz branch
great you call him hey just want to
follow up a good hr person knows how to
do this stuff they'll call the place and
they'll say
hey john this is uh mary giving you a
call we're checking on
you know bob who i think used to work
with you guys and we're doing a
reference call which bob
bob you know such and such bob yes
are you sure you want to hire this
person well yeah they came for an
interview we like them and we're
thinking about they're in the top three
list you want me to be honest with you
what do you want to tell you
well of course we want you to be honest
with you i would never hire this person
let me tell you what this person did and
then they go boom boom boom boom now
that's if you get lucky because a lot of
times they couch it they want to be very
so you have to read between the lines
because they're not
always that open and honest he's right
but he's right but
if you just you can ask questions to say
look if you had to hire them again
would you zero to ten if they say zero
that's all you need to know if they say
we would consider it
okay good that's something i can judge
for it but we would
that we would never hire this person
usually on those usually on those unless
it's somebody who goes out of their way
glowing
stay away yeah so now because when you
want you don't want to hire somebody
mediocre anyway
let me flip it let me flip in the last
18 months in the last 18 months are
there some people that lost their jobs
yes so if i get somebody that tells me
listen i've got to tell you the last 18
months has
been very hard okay what have you done
i've had three jobs
but it's been the businesses went out of
business and i worked four months year
three months here six months here
i'm okay with that i'm like listen
you're trying you're making an effort
all good but we want somebody like that
on the team
let's make an offer to you so we when
you do the interview behind closed doors
those conversations are being hacked
by the way same thing with you what you
just think about what you said earlier
yeah
you said earlier 20 down payment to buy
a house yeah right
and then you said they said your income
isn't to what
well that you had a year your lapse of
income that's exactly the same way we
think about it as well yeah
so your year of laps of income when
underwriter worries about giving you
the loan to buy the house it's the same
thing an employer wonders why you had a
year lapse of no job
yeah because that's that's what that
does that says a lot about how you face
adversity as well yeah
so are you going to say okay i've got
dealt a bad hand and
what was me or are you going to say i
got delta bet hand but here's what i did
here's what i did here's what i did
to try and overcome that because you
know failure is not an option for people
who are winners
you know if you're a winner if you're
determined then you come up with an
obstacle that really shows your
character that you can get past
to be clear this was a once in a century
nothing like this has ever happened
before
situation right so you know like you
can't really
i mean you can but you you can't really
justify
holding an eighteen month block by the
way in
industries yeah in industry so for
example
say i run a big restaurant uh you know
chain hypothetically i'm cheesecake
factory
and i'm hiring a gm and i'm in
california
and you were a gm at applebee's you were
a gm at pick a restaurant wherever you
were at
and you've been a gm for 17 years on
your resume from 2012 to 2019
you've been a waiter you know work your
way up to although being a gm in 2019
2020 happens kova takes place and you're
in california you're like
dude what the hell you want me to do my
industry
has been shut down restaurants and i'm
in california
i have you have credibility with me
because that's situational
of course every restaurant's been shut
down but now
if it's a different industry that you
could have figured out a way to still
work
and you're telling me you couldn't have
a job i'm sorry i don't give you the
credence
yeah so i agree and by the way my
comments of you know you you want to try
and make it work
um the covet issue assad i'm saying in
general you know under
under normal conditions when you see
those lapses
you know you want to understand is this
person making excuses or are they trying
to find answers
very interesting because i and pat you
already know this so i'm not i'm not
dropping any problems here but
i i left i've i've left one job off my
resume my whole life
specifically because i never wanted
anybody to call the boss and and the
reason why
is this dude i was in pharma sales and
um
this dude just was like here it is
incredibly aggressive
like glenn gary glenn ross and he would
he would curse people off like right in
front of everybody get in the room and
just curse everybody off
and i i had exceeded my numbers in the
first quarter
and then they raised my numbers and then
i i didn't hit my numbers in the second
quarter but i hit what i had done before
and he laid into me in front of
everybody he was like this close to my
face
screaming at me in a room full of 20
people and i literally just turned to
him and i went
if you don't get out of my face in the
next five seconds every breath you
breathe will be a gift i grant you
[Laughter]
oh i got fired yeah so
uh i i've told pat this you know
whatever the dude like tried to sit me
down he was like bro that's just
unacceptable you can't say stuff like
that was like bro you're screaming in my
face
right here like i don't know about it i
don't care you know about a job i'm a
man first
i gotta i gotta tell you something i
gotta tell you something so and maybe
this will make sense to you you know my
uh three kids okay i have four kids but
one of them you know she's five weeks
and she just
you know she's got a full-time job of
eating sleeping and nursing that's all
she's doing right
and she makes sure that only gets two
hours of sleep like last night it's her
job it's
she's fully committed to it yeah vampire
dad so
you know tico has a story and some
happens
you know with one of my kids he goes you
know fight breaks out him and another
kid go out and he comes home with a
bunch of scratches on his back
and i said what's this all about he's
got all these scratches well you know he
never wants to tell me about anything
that happens to me he's got too much
pride to complain he's not going to say
it
so but when melva's you know going out
there and seeing his back say daddy some
happened to his back
what happened i don't talk about it
that's kind of how he is he's like legit
omerta like fully committed to this
whole idea so i'm not gonna stop
yeah so i'm like buddy what happened he
says well you know this i said what
happened
is this so i said you know i sit there
as a dad i'm like
you know the the parents whose kids
never do anything wrong my son would
never do such a thing
he would never do such a thing last year
he was taking this
soccer class a year and a half ago i
don't know if you remember this when he
goes to uh soccer class
and he's there he knocks the kid out
okay tiko he flat-out knocks the kid out
and when they kick him out jennifer
calls me and saying patrick got kicked
out of practice
i'm like tico why'd you get kicked out
of practice says daddy i got kicked out
of practice because the guy punched me
in the stomach i said tico do not lie to
me
so i'm telling you i'm not lying to you
he punched me in the stomach you've
taught me to not let bullies bully me
i punched him in the face and then he
went to his mommy and daddy cry mommy
and daddy went to the manager and they
kicked me out of the i'm telling you he
punched me first i said okay
i'm gonna call the owner i call the
owner i tell the owner you know the
story i tell you do you know the story
or no
i called the owner i said hey listen my
kid just got kicked out
yes he says you guys kicked him out why
because he punched a kid in the face and
guy was on the floor
and he knocked him out he can't do that
this is six-year-old eight
seven-year-olds when he did this
i said he's telling me the other kid
punched him in the stomach first you
guys are running kids over there i'm
assuming you have cameras just as we do
i said i want you to go look at the
camera and tell me what happened and i
want you to tell me the story because if
you ever want me to write any positive
review about you
i want to know you guys at the right
thing if we were at fault i'm going to
have my son come and apologize to the
kid
but if the other kids have fault i want
to make sure he's held accountable they
said let us get back to two hours later
they call me like this
uh um here he goes we looked at the
videos and
and your son is right he was punching
the stomach first and then he reacted
but the parents never said i'm like no
[ __ ] but how did they respond to that
though
let me tell you what i did i'm so proud
of that company by the way i will tell
them
recommend them to everybody so i picked
tico up i said let's go
we took him there i said he says sir we
have to apologize to we're so sorry we
made this mistake i said this does
nothing to my character
i don't care you apologize to me like
what apology what does an apology do to
me
i said you need to apologize to my son
because that messed with his character
so i take him over there guy comes up i
says here's my son patrick that's the
coach he says i just want to tell you
patrick you were right you were punching
the stomach first and we kicked you out
we apologize and patrick's like he says
do you accept my apology
no you know
except the apology no accept the apology
okay i accept the apology so he goes to
practice anyways this last week
a similar thing happens he comes from
he's got this whole scratch on his back
this time around i said why'd you get
this well we're playing this game
with kids in school so what's this game
called you're not going to like the game
i said try me
he said i'm telling you you're not going
to like the game i said just tell me the
game he says the game is called
run up to people and call them a name
and run i said there
is no game like that so they ran up this
other kid gave him an idea to run up to
this other kid who was
extremely chubby and they went up them
they called them you know
something something mr fat or something
like that sure and the kid reacts
and again to a fight and he beats him up
so i said okay
i said you understand you bullied the
kid he says no i didn't he bullied me i
said no no you started it
tomorrow you got to go to school you got
to apologize to this kid because that's
not cool
i said if you apologize he doesn't
accept that it's on him but if you
apologize and he bullies you after
you're apologizing you've got to punch
him in the face okay
because you cannot let him bully you
because you did your right thing as a
character if he still wants to bully you
now he's taking advantage the
opportunity to stand up for yourself so
he goes to school apologizes to the kid
i said what happened so we're best
friends now we played all day together
that's a fantastic that's great
what's the moral of the story here's
what i've learned dylan doesn't get
bullied
senna doesn't get bullied patrick
sometimes has these things
because it's probably self-inflicted
when i see people
that get fired too often or they always
have an
issue with a boss and it's always
complaining about the company buddy it's
not the company
and i'm not talking about you i'm
talking about people who come to me for
job interviews
you have an issue you see and you look
for
problems you create problems there's a
reason why you keep losing jobs i called
the guy yesterday
two days ago we're having a conversation
together ask can i ask you a question he
says yeah
i said when you first apply to want to
work at a job this is one of my
insurance companies you said you quit
your business
because you wanted to spend more time
with your family said yes i said so tell
me what kind of money were you making as
a business owner he tells me the number
i said if you were making more money
would you ever shut down the business he
says no it's
because i wasn't spending enough time my
family i wish i was spending more time
my family that's okay i mean every
business owner says that
but most people that were business
owners that become employees is because
you were probably not a good business
owner he didn't know how to manage
a business then you become an employee
and then when you become an employee
if you don't get results eventually you
could get fired as well as an employee
if you're not getting results
so then says well you know it's not that
it's the fact that i have this i have
that i have this
so then an issue comes about the kids
same thing happens as with the kid as
well
so you know what the reality becomes
here's what the reality becomes you said
something uh
uh four weeks ago when we were talking
about somebody he said
people will find a reason to sabotage
themselves to what
yeah to quit something that's hard so
let me wrap up with this and i'll turn
it over to you guys because i've been
listening to you guys for 45 minutes
here's here's here's what will happen
when they sabotage themselves
i have seen more people use family
their kids their faith their past
their parents their upbringing their
ethnicity their nationality the way they
look as an excuse
to not win i can't tell you how many
times i've seen people use all of those
things as excuses
why they can't win versus reasons why
i'm going to go out there make it happen
we all got areas to improve in
if there's anything covert taught us
that exploited expose a lot of our
weaknesses
every one of us let me tell you all my
businesses the weaknesses were shown
all of them when insurance when this
thing when [ __ ] hit the fan
march 12 we never sold the policy on
zoom ever
we had no clue how to sell a policy on
zoom i'm at the office so four o'clock
in the morning saying
how the hell am i going to teach people
how to sell policy on a zoom i've never
sold a policy on the zoom
we sit in kneecap to kneecap we don't
sit zoom in talking to you
we got exposed we have to sit down so we
got to justice really quickly
we're driven on a convention-based event
we run offices people go to offices
leases
all this stuff that we everybody got
exposed in the last 18 months
either you improved and you did
something about it and you made a ton of
money or you didn't
the reality is the last nine months made
more money than my entire career
because we made the right adjustments
people who made the right adjustments
made a lot of money in the last 18
months but if you didn't
here's what the marketplace just found
out about you
uh everything that you were able to hide
the last 18 months there were bad
qualities to not hired officially got
exposed
that's what the market the last 18
months the last 18 months
showed why the market doesn't pay you
what you think you're worth that's the
thing about the market the market
sucks the market is like a six-year-old
kid that will say
hey mr patrick can i ask you a question
yes why is your nose so big and crooked
what do you tell a six-year-old kid he
ain't lying he's gonna say no it's not
yes it is why is your nose so big and
cricket you know cause i've broken it
four times
and i got a big nose what are you gonna
do about it yeah but it looks very weird
i've never seen a nose like that before
right okay that's what a kid will do
last 18 months the market said you're
lazy you're this
you don't want to improve you got a big
ego you think you know it all you make
excuses
in the last 18 months we got brutal
honesty from the market nonstop
don't get me wrong it's been a tough
last 18 months it's been challenging
it's been annoying it's been difficult
for a lot of us believe me
i'm on more late night calls the last 18
months than i've ever been in my career
been in business for 20 years
a lot of late night calls but the
reality of it is we got to expose the
last 18 months it either favored you or
it didn't
so that's what i would say when you're
talking about that whole story with some
people last 18 months when we're hiring
people
i know people in the last 18 months that
made very big names for themselves
that did a lot of good for themselves
anyway so that's that's what it is when
it comes down to
unemployment if you're out there and
you're still collecting unemployment
checks
i got a bigger question for you you know
what the bigger question is the
following
what the hell are your dreams what are
your dreams
have you compromised all of your dreams
have you compromised all your dreams for
a flip and paycheck
you mean a 4 000 a month stimulus check
is worth you
compromising your dreams for the rest of
your life i don't understand that
part you mean to tell me when you watch
a movie like pursuit of happiness
and you see a story of chris gardner
whom i brought up in 2008 in front of
five thousand people with mary lou rhett
and i intro them
at an event you see a story like chris
gardner how he wins on pursuit of
happiness
and at the end he wins and he's a
multi-million and he wins for his son
you tell me that doesn't get you
emotional
of course you mean to tell me when you
watch rocky and he wins and you see the
robots and rocky iv and all this other
stuff and his dreams are becoming a
reality you mean to tell me that doesn't
fire you up to want to do 200 push-ups
afterwards
you mean to tell me when you watch some
of these movies and people's dreams are
becoming a reality you're not sitting
there saying
i have some dreams biggest thing with
the stimulus is the fastest way
to steal you from dreaming and it's the
easiest way
to get you to control because the more
you dream and you
innovate and you challenge status quo
the more they lose
the more they give you money and you
stop thinking about dreaming reading
books improving yourself the easier you
are to control
so if there's anything when it comes
down to money being given away to us
you just have to keep thinking about i
get it three months i get it two months
i get it a month i get it four months
maybe six months
if it's 18 months you kind of you know
exploiting the opportunity getting more
money and quite frankly
you decrease your market value in the
last 18 months while
inflation went up while everything is
more expensive so you're kind of going
to be very broke the next five years
and life's gonna be very hard you
thought it was hard two years ago shit's
about to hit the fan the next five years
this is why you want to use
opportunities like this to recreate
yourself and many did barry
oh i totally agree with you i mean this
is when you have an adversity you either
decide to make an opportunity out of it
or it's what was me so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye